uh all right let's speak next
to ivan from california
ivan from california you're on the air
david can you hear me yes i can oh
excellent
oh wow david deepak pakman um okay
so um yeah something i've been thinking
about lately
is um to what point could we
call the republican party fascist or
like crypto fascist or is that even like
productive
because i think it's not productive i
think i think i've been using more of
the term
here's the way i i've been seeing it
because sometimes when you
when you over label you you just damage
yourself
trump is authoritarian and he has
fascistic tendencies
and i think he would love to be a
dictator if he could get away with it
but
saying this is a fascist administration
trump's desires are fascistic uh
i i don't know that we get that much
from saying
this is fascism and i think it's sort of
uh
discounts real fascism that we've seen
in practice i think trump has fascistic
delusions
i see i see okay um
thank you um can i ask you a little
quickie sure yeah go ahead
so i'm sure you're familiar with jorge
luis borges of course
of course um any other great argentine
writers i should
look into yeah um you know actually let
me
let's see one i don't know if you've
read let me remember which one
the uh which which uh okay so so
certainly um julio cortazar
is fantastic and he wrote the novel
um which is hopscotch translated in
english and a bunch of short stories
that are really good i would dig into
some of that
oh lovely thank you so much uh peace and
love thank you all right
peace and love peace and love thank you
so much great to hear from you
a lot of references a lot of memetic
references in that call for sure
let's go next to uh
where did we want to go a lot of people
just listening which is totally
fine i'm not going to force you in let's
go to
um let's go to roland
from vienna
roland from vienna
roland from vienna david hello how are
you
david great great great listen congrats
on the
georgia runoff yes
i'm i'm a 40 year old white male from
the middle of europe
okay but uh is it weird to say that
stacy abrams is my new hero
no no i mean what she's been able to do
is is incredible it's
you know earlier we had that call about
democrats failing on organizing
stacey abram stacey abrams should be
explaining to
national democrats how to organize quite
frankly
yeah that's in fact the only downside
i'm seeing is uh
uh it's all good for chuck schumer to be
in the driving seat now
but why did nancy pelosi have to stay
there right
well listen i mean i think um the the
truth is that
what really matters is sort of like the
average
uh placement on the political spectrum
of the house and senate
and the senate has been pulled a little
to the left with the addition of ossoff
and warnock
and or significantly to the left and the
house even though democrats lost seats
some of the people who won
are more left so i think i think it's
okay i think there's a realistic chance
to get some important things done here
well you'll get there you'll get there
listen dave thanks a lot for what you're
doing
to be honest i i started watching you
about a year ago
yes and i started watching for the
political commentary
and then i kept watching for the comedy
it is
especially your live streams i just it's
hilarious so much fun
uh with the callers also and i think
it's time for a spin-off show
really and what would the spin-off be
like you're saying a spin-off comedy
show
yeah yeah you have the uh um yeah maybe
some
viewer generated contact i know you have
and i'm also a big fan of your
your uh one of your uh regular call-ins
to the voicemail the eggman
yes of course eggman is is a fantastic
caller
roland i like that idea we'll take that
under advisement maybe
a scripted comedy my middle name my
middle name is egbert so it's going to
be eggbert and the eggman
i'm gonna connect with that guy and
we'll make it happen for you david
let's do it all right yes eggman and egg
bert let's put everybody together
have a good one okay thanks there's a
roland from vienna
very very excited uh to do a
collab with the eggman